air raid sirens sounded in the early
morning dawn light here in la vie
signaling incoming cruise missiles from
the black sea
four of those cruise missiles struck the
international airport in la vie they
struck an airplane repair facility
nobody was working in the facility at
the time the mayor said but one person
was injured two more missiles were shot
down by ukrainian air defense systems
according to the ukrainian military it's
not clear where the remnants of those
missiles may have collapsed around la
vie
this is the second major attack on navi
in under a week using similar kinds of
missiles and authorities here say they
are expecting more and that it shows the
russians are in fact targeting civilians
lev has become a humanitarian hub
millions have fled to this part of the
country from their towns and cities
which are being shelled by the russians
authorities here say the willingness to
target lavive where there is not a
military structure within the city shows
a willingness to target those civilians
and they say that in this war they
expect that there could be more missile
strikes at any given time and they are
prepared for that but they are concerned
given the number of civilians and
humanitarian crisis that is happening in
the city as well as the proximity to the
polish border which is where aid is
being transported across
mercedes stephenson global news la viv